he could take king f1 and king f1 and we
got in on our goddamn punches but the
king just left yeah
that's we have a guess that can't wait
his opinions
why he wants to show you know he's ready
to be a commentator i don't even know if
it's a good move
how many rooks okay
i'm just pranking your guys we're we're
safe we're safe for a day
finally proving to wesley so that
commentary is harder than playing chess
of course he's got it easy being a
player
[Laughter]
welcome welcome wesley welcome wesley so
here wesley a fine win today uh you
could be three and oh i don't want to
remind you about that first game you
said you couldn't sleep afterwards but
the train is rolling right now
yeah that's right i had a very good
start i never started the think field
cup like this i think i played
uh this is my sixth sink field cup or my
if i'm correct
and i finished close the laugh in five
of those or in four of those events
you did win one i did win one i was 16
finished last saw 15 finished tie four
last 17 eight
seconds left 18 and tie four last one
thousand nineteen so i have quite a good
record but it's the first time i've had
this good start i think
uh before i only ever won plus one uh
before round three once
so it's really a big achievement
this game let me get this game on the
screen are we going to live out their
games though
no no no no
it's your game let's get to it where did
you think he went wrong was allowing
this b4 break
yeah that story you're right maybe after
castle i thought on move 13 he can play
a4 but apparently the engine doesn't
like i thought he can play a4 here
because
the
united a4 knight e2
takes bishop a4 b4 bishop c6 and i
thought this
looks okay for black because he's got
one pawn island versus two
so i thought a4 here
but he missed something i'm sure like on
move
move 16
i'm sure he missed after rook takes b4
he missed after b5 i can just play
knight d5 and let's pull that up on your
board yes yeah if you may
yeah i'm pretty sure that's what he
missed
because yeah after b5
he probably missed knight d5 and if
knight takes
knight takes he cannot play bc4 because
of rook b8 and knight e7
so i'm pretty sure that's what he missed
because otherwise he just wants to trade
off all the queenside pawns
but in the game after bishop g2 king
ju27
uh white has a very pleasant position
and i think yasser likes this position
very much very much wesley you play the
english yes the the this for me is kind
of a dream achievement uh
the knight on d5 uh can't be
kicked away and the rook
bearing down on the backward pawn
we thought your advantage was good we
just didn't realize how good i mean how
did
in computer terms did you see this as a
one point two point three point
advantage what did you feel
yeah i know why that's a stable
advantage but during the game of course
i don't know the assessment
but
i also don't didn't know how to make
progress so i was playing f3 bishop e3 i
thought rook f7 was too slow
maybe he had to play knight e6 and just
play bishop e3 and then g5 and start
pushing everything like g5
quindy to f4
and then bishop f2h5
but probably wouldn't work
i thought he has to start pushing some
points in knight e4 g4
but because in the game he didn't really
get anything going
like he was trying to slowly improve his
position but i was also improving my
position by playing
like yeah it would be one i mean the
problem if he plays h4 it just always
takes the pawn
so even though i'm not sure how to make
progress here i had
control over the position
against h4
and i think
yeah here it's with night coming e4 but
uh after knight cd4 he he also missed
bishop takes d4 i thought he could still
play knight xd4 but probably losing also
knight before knight e4 knight f5
knight g5 94-95 flag play knight g5 king
g8
knight f7 knight h4 king h2 win f7
and then i can play with d6 or d4
yeah rook takes maybe
maybe bishop e5 b6
the rook on b1 or the rook on d6 yeah
well we keep them at their aliens
keep the material did you hear that
first
nice a very nice game wesley thank you
but wesley one of the things that was
really remarkable for us right here
the computer assesses the position as
plus
five advantage wow after night before
yes after knight d4 plus
five like you're a rook ahead wow
a rook ahead that was a shock for we
think well material yeah for alejandro
and i we're like
myself
i think the computer's gotten to a point
where it's just super strong and super
crazy that no human can ever compete
like
uh when i check my games afterwards with
a computer it's just so incredible their
their mouth and mouth ahead of us
wesley you're doing really well well
that game was dominant you're in first
place right now
fabi's looking really good also yeah in
this this position clearly he's winning
as we see we see this position yeah
you're slowly crashing you play him
tomorrow what are your thoughts on that
ah it's going to be really crucial i
have the black pieces uh
i mean he's number two player in the
world right so
he's
a very strong very well prepared player
uh sometimes he can have good days or
bad days like in his match against
magnus he played uh really well
uh
i think last last three tournaments
maybe he's not playing as well as he he
can
so it it's going to be
really
really exciting and you feel he's going
to come after you yeah definitely
fabi plays for a win with both callers
today i thought the game was a bit
complex
against wyrix but he he just succeeds
uh he just aims to play people and he
plays for a win with both callers so
all right well while we have you wesley
since you did want to
if you analyze help us out yesterday you
can pull out the game between mamedyarov
and rapport
and i had a question in this position
you can have on your screen in just just
a bit
what happens on the move rook takes h2
now right now
okay i know maurice engine doesn't give
it well we're gage too
i'm a resource engineer
that's not not shiny no cheating don't
show him anything touch them
i'm shocked myself what a move wow ah
maybe there's queen a3 king e8
queen a3 check king goes
back to e8
and then can i play knight three seven
night sorry west nile night 57
not sure
spicy nightwear c7 knight c7 check
that's a move spicy bishop t7 bishop a4
that is a nice
big six king of fate queen a3
big sex king of fade
take
excuse me this rook is supposed to come
across the board
king of eight
and it's still very unclear huh
there is uh queen f who is coming ah
that's a crazy line right there how
about
we can probably
yeah this is very unclear so maybe
except knight c7 is there anything else
maybe later king 896 we have this rook
h2
yeah rook h2
uh yeah i guess white has to play queen
eight three
he played queen c5 in the game wow rook
h2 is
rook h2 that's very visual great idea
but also i can
also play rook e3
rook e3 uh blocking the f2
uh
yeah and queen a3 is a powerful thread
but rook 83 doesn't seem lack of
anything decisive
nothing decisive here not worried about
something like rook g3 or
anything huh roger fg3
no i'm worried but
we have do you think
we work c2
oh okay now we have brookfield golly
this is
see this is
it's tough being a commentator
and then you got to put it out there
white's winning
nobody believes
but you've got to say it assertively
very absolutely that's the key of being
a commentator don't
let on any weakness never shy away
what's that oh god oh it's a drag queen
a
uh
wesley we've got a graphic for you
your lifetime score before we show it we
oh i wanted to ask you if you knew what
it was
uh there it is uh four wins three losses
21
draws that's a lot of draws i have four
losses
yeah that's what the graphic says
in classical chess we're not talking
about rapid and blitz yeah that's true
yeah so not bad pretty good man pretty
good against the number two player in
the world yeah that's amazing that's a
nice record yeah yeah i i
well yeah i mean tomorrow is going to be
very exciting but that's a favorite but
if i could ask you who's your best
paying customer
and
who do you hate playing against first of
all
who who who do you have the best score
against and who do you have the worst
scores in this tournament no in general
in general
uh well i have a terrible result against
magnus i think i only beat him classical
game once oof
and uh
you're best paying customer
uh
best paying customer yeah used to be ian
nepanji but if i beat him like five
times in a row a few years ago not bad
i need to challenge you to the world
championship but then he's he's much
stronger now uh
let's see best being awesome
how many times did he beat you back yeah
i think he beat me
two times
okay okay so he turned five to two i'm
not bad at a pretty good score against
netflix in terms of classical uh
i think my result against magnus is
pretty terrible but against everyone
else it's it's okay i haven't beaten
shaq yet
uh
let's see i don't really have a customer
uh per se
well five in a row sounded like the
customer i've ever found yeah
we will let you go you've really been
generous with your time
get your rest and prepare for the war
tomorrow against fabi thank you speaking
of fabulous